une production du studio SF
bienvenue au sans filtre présenté par
Keith me le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut que nous inviter d'atsea avec
moi Doom plant vous savez la santé
mentale ce jeu qui est encore un peu
tabou puis c'est important d'en parler
d'en parler plus c'est pour ça que Kiss
Me s'est associé avec Narcisse
montréalaise qui est aussi doctorante en
psycho pour faire trois étui dans le
fond où est-ce que en lien avec la santé
mentale puis sur chaque étui qui est
vendu il y a 5 dollars qui sont remises
à l'Association canadienne de la santé
mentale donc c'est le temps de commencer
à parler puisque le temps d'encourager
la cause en plus les étuis sont
magnifiques donc dès le 8 juillet vous
allez avoir accès à ces étuis là on a un
nouveau code promo pour vous qui est le
sans filtre 20 donc assurez-vous
utiliser le bon code promo assurez-vous
aussi d'utiliser notre code promo pour
montrer à qui est semi que c'est nous
qui vous envoie sinon d'homme cette
semaine cette semaine on a le grand
plaisir de recevoir un professeur à la
Faculté de Pharmacie d'une version
Montréal
François-Xavier Lacasse est aussi
résultat dans l'industrie pharmaceutique
on a parlé des médicaments on a parlé
bien sûr de vaccin le covid essayer de
démystifier tout ça voir c'est quoi les
les bonnes les moins bonnes informations
entourant la vaccination entourant la
deuxième dose en tourant les effets
secondaires entourant la propagation de
ce virus là c'était super intéressant
quelqu'un qui connaît son domaine sur le
bout de ses doigts grand plaisir de
discuter avec lui yes juste avant
d'aller à la conversation on va les
remercier nos sponsors le podcast de
cette semaine est présenté encore une
fois par hochlag le fournisseur officiel
de boissons alcoolisées du studio SF
avec nos clients si vous venez ici vous
louez le studio on vous offre la hushlag
que ce soit les bières de micro que ce
soit les spiritueux de distillerie que
ce soit les Celtes sur qui sont qui sont
à la mode tu t'es découvert une passion
pour les statuts surtout pour les hlines
moi le
grand al
[Musique]
c'est des produits magnifiques merci à
chaque d'être avec nous depuis si
longtemps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parfait merci d'être avec nous c'est un
plaisir c'est un plaisir partagé yes
justement qu'on tombe dans le vif du
sujet le juste pour ceux qui nous
écoutent peux-tu nous expliquer ton
parcours mon parcours bon moi je me
présente je m'appelle François-Xavier
Lacasse je suis professeur à la Faculté
de pharmacie de l'Université de Montréal
je suis un peu reproduit l'Université de
Montréal c'est à dire j'ai fait toutes
mes études univers de Montréal mes trois
cycles universitaires un purlane
ton bac à une place ta maîtrise un autre
place ton doctorat nos places donc moi
j'étais bien sur mon appartement je suis
resté comme ça
[Rires]
Université de Montréal et puis de fil en
aiguille j'ai commencé à enseigner quand
j'étais aux études graduées maîtrise
d'octobre donc j'enseigne depuis 1984 et
quand j'ai fini mon docteur j'ai
commencé une carrière moi je m'en allais
en industrie ça je travaille en
industrie pharmaceutique chose que j'ai
fait que j'ai faite comme en tant
qu'employé puis ensuite en 2003 j'ai
ouvert ma compagnie incorporée de
consultation fait que je fais de la
consultation en développement de
médicaments donc j'aide les couper je
fais plus ou moins la même chose que ce
que je faisais quand j'étais employé
sauf que là je suis consultant donc
j'aide des compagnies généralement ce
qu'on appelle les bibliothèques les
compagnons démarrage à développer leur
molécules exemple au hasard pour la
covid au hasard pour autre chose donc
c'est ça donc je suis un je fais les
deux professeurs et consultant en
développement médicament c'est ça
c'est compagnies-là les compagnies de
développement de médicaments là c'est
quoi situation Canada de ça il y en a
dessus beaucoup c'est une excellente
question le Canada est très très bien
placé au niveau des compagnons c'est
vraiment spécialisé puis il y a fortiori
au Québec à cause des fameux crédits
d'impôts ok il y a beaucoup de crédits
d'impôts donc c'est des avantages
fiscaux très intéressants pour les
compagnies on s'est vraiment spécialisé
je dirais en ce qu'on appelle en
développement précoce de médicaments
donc vraiment faire de la découverte de
molécules et faire ce qu'on appelle les
premières études cliniques chez des
volontaires sains exemple ok parce que
c'est sûr que les compagnies de
bibliothèque on parle de compagnie
maintenant qui sont maintenant
virtuelles de plus en plus donc on parle
pas de compagnies avec exemple 50-100
200 personnes on parle de compagnie il y
a peut-être deux à quatre personnes au
départ ouais donc c'est sûr que je parle
de développement précoce parce
qu'ensuite quand vous rentrez dans du
développement de phase 2 comme on dit
phase 3 exemple commune pour les vaccins
il faut beaucoup de monde donc
généralement qu'est-ce qu'on fait ces
compagnies-là quand le produit est
prometteur en phase 1re études chez les
volontaires sains
ils vont faire ce qu'on appelle une
licence c'est ou alors ils vont faire un
partenariat avec une plus grosse
compagnie prenez par exemple justement
le vaccin de Pfizer
bio-entechizer ou alors exemple moderna
ou ce qu'on a au Québec médico
médicaments qui va sortir un vaccin
bientôt ils sont aussi avec des grosses
remontes pour toutes sortes de raisons
qui il y a des raisons d'affaires mais
aussi des raisons de gestion de projet
eux exemple c'est glaxos des grosses
compagnies et on le sait faire une étude
à 50 000 personnes exactement
donc la biotech voit très bien au Canada
il y a beaucoup d'incubateurs Montréal
c'est le pipeline il y a beaucoup de
compagnies même de l'Ouest canadien ben
couvert qui viennent s'installer au
Québec à cause des incitatives des
crédits d'impôts donc ça ça va très bien
très très bien puis le l'espèce de
d'idée qu'on a le parce que je sais que
certaines compagnies qui ou est-ce
qu'ils sont ils sont allés dans des pays
où est-ce que les normes de recherche
sont moins strictes est-ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est un mythe ça ou c'est
vrai
parce que je sais qu'ici mettons il y a
des certaines limites puis sur par
exemple les tests sur sur animaux c'est
des limites qu'on peut faire bah alors
que d'autres pays ont pas ces normes là
est-ce que c'est vrai que certaines
compagnies biotech
se sont mauvais vers ou migrer vers des
endroits où est-ce que les normes
étaient mon plus flexible moins rigide
pour être capable d'accélérer le
processus puis c'était vrai ça allait
probablement toujours bon je dirais
qu'il y a de l'homme il y a de l'omery
mais de moins en moins dans la mesure où
une espèce d'harmonisation mondiale pour
la réglementation des études cliniques
exemple pour les animaux on s'accroît
maintenant même que les animaux sont
quasiment mieux traités que les humains
dans les études cliniques les études
cliniques comme ça exemple
dans tous les cas que ce soit des
animaux ou des humains tu dois justifier
ton âme tu peux pas dire regarde je vais
prendre 50 000 euros faut que tu dis je
veux tant d'euros pour faire tant
d'études ça passe devant un comité
d'éthique pour les animaux au Canada il
y a ce qu'on appelle la Canadian cancer
ok qui va vérifier aussi des protocoles
c'est qu'il va dire oui tu as le droit
tant d'animaux ou pas ou j'en ai refait
ça puisque c'est pas juste le nombre
d'animaux ça oui tu veux faire ça
pourquoi est-ce que tu serais obligé de
faire tel tester c'est vraiment pour
amener ça au strict minimum de
l'essentiel donc pour amener ça oui
c'est à dire pas plus que ce qu'on en a
exactement besoin exactement
chez les humains dans le temps c'est
vrai que la réglementation n'était pas
la même exemple je me rappelle dans les
années 70-80 c'était beaucoup le
Royaume-Uni on pouvait aller en clinique
très rapidement chez des volontaires
sains avec tout le monde allait là ok by
the way il y a pas plus de morts il y a
pas eu plus de morts
dans le front l'argent des choses qui
leur ont poussé non il y avait vraiment
passé
donc mais bon de plus en plus il y a une
réglementation il y a une inflation
réglementaire qui est absolument hors
norme qui très bien d'un point de vue
sécurité des animaux sécurité des
volontaires sains vous savez quand on
fait des études sur des médicaments
qu'on est des volontaires sains j'ai
fait ça pendant deux ans c'est peut-être
pour ça que je suis rendu comme ça
d'ailleurs je suis rendu à prendre cette
café alors exactement et donc il y a une
réglementation c'est qui il y a une
inflation réglementaire qui fait en
sorte qu'on augmente vraiment de façon
majeure
la sécurité des animaux la sécurité des
volontaires la sécurité des patients par
contre ça se reflète aussi en termes sur
les prix ça se refait aussi sur d'autres
choses comme exemple quand il y a des
c'est pour ça exemple que les pays du
briques brisés de Russie en Chine vont
fabriquer majoritairement pourquoi parce
que les salaires sont moins élevés donc
ton coût à la fin est moins élevé donc
la marge que tu vas faire va quand même
être là alors que exemple c'est un peu
comme l'industrie une facture au Canada
c'est maintenant c'est tout parti est
exemples les jeans sur n'importe quoi
moi je me rappelle dans le temps le
principe est le même que pour les
t-shirts comportent exactement c'est
exactement le même fait si tu veux faire
un peu de profit puis encore une fois
comme je vous disais le Québec étant la
province la moins chère pour des
médicaments ça donne accès à des
médicaments oui mais comme tu as une
inflation réglementaire qui demande une
augmentation des coûts au niveau de la
qualité de la surveillance d'un moment
donné ça
ça va se reflète sur la qualité tout
autant
exagéré ou nécessaire à mon Dieu toutes
ces réponses bien sûr encore une fois
moi ce que je dis ce que je dis ne
regarde que moi ok je parle au nom de
personne c'est vraiment mon opinion là
dedans j'ai écrit un article d'ailleurs
sur l'inflation réglementaire
ou d'ailleurs j'ai signé comme
professeur université
d'ailleurs j'ai eu des réponses
là-dessus dans la mesure où
l'inflation réglementaire est aussi au
niveau politique mais au niveau
économique est au niveau aussi je dirais
apprentissage parce que j'enseigne moi
le développement du médicament à
l'université je vois les gens qui sont
qui font ces réglementations là
je leur ai enseigné bon ok je détends
grise un peu mais j'ai juste 51 ans
qui t'as très intelligents la question
n'est jamais seule problème c'est que
quand tu as jamais été confronté exemple
à du Handzone c'est développement
médicament ça implique quoi et que tu ne
fais qu'appliquer tu la Loi sur les
aliments et drogues de façon bête et
méchante et que tu ne l'as pas adapté
aux besoins
maintenant c'est rendu comme carrément
ces gens-là il y a des nouvelles lois
des nouvelles lois des nouvelles lois
réglementaires qui fait en sorte que
même au niveau ça va même au niveau
exemple de l'entrepreneurial si exemple
vous avez envie d'ouvrir un laboratoire
d'analyses pharmaceutique je pense qu'il
y aura du beau soyons sarcastique je
pense que vous aurez plus de chance à
ouvrir une raffinerie de pétales
aujourd'hui
malgré l'environnement c'est rendu
maintenant
l'entrepreneurship c'est exemple une
coupe de jeunes des chimistes
dans l'opinion publique il y a souvent
une genre de méfiance envers les
compagnies pharmaceutiques comme de quoi
tout à fait ils s'en mettent plein les
poches comme de quoi café
mais pas une arnaque mais dans le sens
que c'est vraiment
lucratif c'est
aussi qui est aussi dans le dans cette
dans ce que tu dis là l'idée que on
garde certaines informations pour
continuer à vendre des médicaments
ce que vous dites je l'entends c'est
vrai par contre bon il y a le fait aussi
encore une fois que c'est de la des
informations de la mauvaise information
moi j'ai travaillé en industrie
pharmaceutique c'est une excellente
industrie ça reste une industrie qui
donne de très bons salaires qui donnent
de très bonnes conditions puis qui quand
même découvre des médicaments bon les
langues sales vont vous dire que
les compagnies pharmaceutiques ne
veulent pas vous guérir parce que sinon
avant de pilules
ok mais bon c'est facile à dire mais
c'est plus difficile à faire à l'heure
actuelle les médicaments des médicaments
qu'on dit curatifs
il y en a pas des masques des
antibiotiques quand tu fais une
infection et exemple quand tu
cholestérol quand tu fais des pertension
tu prends ça à vie on a tous comme
jamais étudiants c'est exemple des
grands-parents qui prennent un petit
cocktail de personnage et comme on dit
hypertension cholestérol le cœur ça
marche très bien
sauf qu'à un moment donné c'est sûr que
si arrête de le prendre
savoir commencer mais l'adage puis tout
le monde pense aussi mes étudiants
moitié je le vois en début d'année
l'image que tu as de l'industrie
pharmaceutique c'est qu'on gagne tout un
million qu'on a toutes des piscines
curiosité des hélicoptères et des shorts
la Kiev puis tout c'est pas vrai c'est
pas le cas j'ai pas dit que c'est
mauvais industrie c'est une excellente
industrie qui est très florissante puis
qui embauche bien moi je le vois on a 0
% de chômage à la Faculté de Pharmacie
tout le monde se place mais il y a une
adage aussi exemple je faisais des tests
de médicaments
par la population on est vraiment vu
comme des Frankenstein
imaginez quand il se passe quelque chose
puis que ça sort d'un jour nous oublie
ça là c'est carrément c'est du
Frankenstein qui se passe quelque chose
exemple qu'est-ce qui pourrait se passer
il y a deux types de médicaments que tu
peux tester soit des médicaments
génériques ok bon ben là à ce moment les
effets secondaires exemple sont connus
puisque c'est les médicaments qui
existent déjà fait c'est de la copie ça
c'est que généralement les gens on en
avoir moins parler la population les
volontaires qui font ça sont pas
vraiment inquiétés parce que c'est
exemple un générique d'aspirine qui
sortait de l'aspirine
par exemple au hasard
qu'est-ce qu'il fait exactement mais
quand c'est des médicaments nouveaux
novateurs
chez l'animal avant mais attention les
gens savent pas vraiment aussi comment
ça se passe quand tu es volontaire pour
une étude comme ça tu vas venir à la
compagnie on va te faire un speech
complet puis c'est tout écrit exemple
les effets secondaires qui a eu chez
l'animal de A à Z et tu vas signer un
document comme quoi tu as écouté et tolu
à présent l'animal n'est pas un humain
il peut se passer des choses que chez
l'animal qui aura pas chez les mains et
vice versa ok sauf que tu le fais en
connaissance de cause puis vous allez me
dire c'est un peu si tu avais pas ça il
y aurait pas de nouveaux médicaments
c'est que c'est un peu puis on va tester
des doses de façon croissante si on
donne pas de suite une dose de cheval
c'est un jeu de mots là si tu veux
commencer des petites doses d'attendre
24 heures tu regardes comment la corde
de 10 personnes exemple réagit il y a un
comité qui se réunit bon il y a rien
aucun vomissement est-ce que un
vomissement oui non il y a rien bon on
passe à la deuxième dose la deuxième
dose c'est pas 10 fois plus
c'est tout déterminé par un comité
d'éthique aussi avant de faire une étude
là c'est compliqué c'est très compliqué
c'est pas genre on s'en va chez l'animal
on a fait l'animal on s'en va chez
l'humain une suite ok Google on prend
des gens les compensations financières
qui ont exemple c'est pas les compagnies
qui décident de il y a un comité
d'éthique qui décide on peut pas dire oh
on n'arrive pas à recruter des gens on
va monter ça de 500 pièces ne marche pas
comme ça c'est très compliqué le
studieux c'est si tu arrives pas à
recruter on peut essayer d'augmenter la
rémunération pour les volontaires mais
ça se fait pas en disant bah tiens
finalement on met du tape puis on met
1000 pièces au lieu de 500 non non pour
proposer comité d'éthique tatata est-ce
que oui est-ce que non c'est quoi le
risque tatata encore une fois c'est de
l'information qu'il faut connaître mais
c'est sûr qu'il y a un espèce de trou
noir t'a jamais testé un médicament
quand tu dis il y a quelque chose quand
il y a quelque chose qui arrive sur
cette journée là on est perçu comme des
Frankenstein c'est dans des cas
extrêmement rare où est-ce qu'il y
aurait des effets secondaires graves par
exemple moi je me souviens oui par
exemple ou même quand les volontaires
n'appliquent pas le règlement qu'on leur
imposé je me rappelle quand je
travaillais dans les années au milieu
des années 2000 exemple quelqu'un en
fait une étude exemple qui va durer
exemple trop weekend vous venez 3
weekends de suite ok
vous avez pas le droit de voyager entre
les deux
signes il y en a un qui est parti
nintitropie qui est revenu avec la
tuberculose
il y a pas ça tuberculose à 47 personnes
c'est un dommage collatéral qui est dû
au fait que tu as des rejets
et la compagnie qui faisait cette étude
là c'est elle qui a mangé à claque sauf
que quelque part senti Canada quand ils
sont venus parce qu'ils ont réglé ça
avec Santé Canada il y a eu une nouvelle
réglementation pour la tuberculose avec
des nouveautés que tu vas passer à
chaque fois pour être sûr que tu l'as
pas
c'est un peu comme les guerres un peu
comme exemple finalement la covid dans
la mesure où il faut des choses un peu
en guillemets c'est dommage
catastrophique pour que les choses se
développent pour que ouais pour que ça
aille de plus en plus vite finalement on
arrive avec de plus en plus de
réglementation pour la sécurité des gens
puis maintenant qu'on prend un
le développement d'un vaccin
prenons les étapes d'un vaccin normal
comment ça se fait c'est parce que j'ai
l'impression que dans toutes les
la résistance de certains à se faire
vacciner pour la covid parce que on
comprend très mal c'est quoi un vaccin
puis en quoi ça consiste le tuer faites
prenons un vaccin normal puis après ça
qu'on part en là au vaccin de la covid
dans le processus de développement pour
essayer de comprendre toutes les étapes
jusqu'à ce que la population générale
dans le
brasciné deux fois
on parlons de ça allons-y comme ça
j'aime votre question ta question
c'est une autre question
où il y a une mauvaise information oui
si ce n'était que de la mauvaise
information parce que les gens ne
comprennent pas ce serait très bien le
problème aussi c'est qu'il y a quand
même des
c'est quoi le terme c'est complexiste ou
c'est comme il y a des gens qui vont
dire carrément on rentrera pas dans
l'histoire de 5 juillet non non
veulent pas se faire vacciner une grosse
raison c'est pour ça mais que si ce
n'était que de la mauvaise compréhension
ce serait le fun en guillemets parce que
la limite on pourrait penser quand
l'expliquant et en l'expliquant
peut-être que les gens deviendraient
plus enclins
je vais rajouter aussi une parenthèse le
développement d'un vaccin de façon
conventionnelle ok même par rapport par
exemple un médicament conventionnel
Jean-Paul maladie Jean hypertension
cholestérol c'est différent aussi bon en
moyenne pour développer un médicament il
faut à peu près je dirais 10 à 12 ans ok
ça peut être un peu moins ça peut être
un peu plus mais en moyenne c'est 10 à
12 ans puis OK
ça va être long comme réponse
ça se récompense ma question ça va être
en fait ce temps-là si long en
guillemets c'est sur les tests qui sont
longs c'est dessus le développement de
la molécule j'ai toutes ces réponses
toutes
parce que au départ généralement quand
on dit 10 à 12 ans
c'est que on part du départ de plusieurs
molécules ok de plusieurs on va dire
molécules dans ce que là c'est des
biologiques ce sont des molécules
biologiques qui sont différentes du
salbutamol exemple qui est une molécule
chimique de synthèse donc il y en a
plusieurs qu'on va tester mettons juste
chimique de synthèse qu'elle a été créée
de messager exemple du vacciner qu'on
vous injecte qui code pour la protéine S
la fameuse spicule S c'est une molécule
biologique faites un produit naturel
dans le fond
naturel et beaucoup de gens qui en
prennent parce que c'est écrit naturel
dessus alors que ça ne l'est pas du tout
pipi qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
finalement naturel aussi il y a un genre
de flou exactement
[Musique]
parenthèse sur un supplément pour le
sport le sport d'endurance
d'entraînement dans le fond puis là je
suis en train de faire une demande de
numéro de produit naturel la Santé
Canada mais dans le fond pin dans le
fond faut juste que tu payes selon le si
tu vends ton numéro quand même il faut
juste tu payes selon le palier de
naturel que tu es puisqu'on est le même
exactement puis maintenant ils ont
changé pour avoir pour pouvoir le mettre
danser c'est que exactement beaucoup
moins
il amène beaucoup moins d'études pour un
produit sentier naturel que pour un
médicament et il y a un problème parce
que parenthèse on s'éloigne un peu en
restant dans le champ par contre c'est
que il y a beaucoup de gens qui en
prennent parce que c'est en vente libre
puis ben le problème c'est que beaucoup
exemples d'interactions avec les
médicaments que tu prends pour les
personnes âgées les médicaments qui sont
pas en vente exactement les gens qui
sont en polycémification comme j'étais
en tout exemple je parlais de mon petit
cocktail de personnage ou même des gens
qui ont des maladies chroniques exemple
qui font du salbutamol est-ce que si tu
prends un produit santé naturel une
interaction qui va faire en sorte que ça
va inhiber dans cette vitamol l'activer
c'est pas testé
le côté naturel oui peut-être que la
molécule est naturelle puis en plus puis
on va faire ma parenthèse si tu prends
des affaires la grive du chat la griffe
du diable la griffe du chien
naturel ce sont des extraits qui
contiennent des centaines de molécules
cette vitamol c'est une molécule c'est
celle finalement l'aspirine c'est de
l'aspirine la vitamine exemple ça pose
naturelle c'est de la vitamine homme et
la plupart de ces produits là sont des
extraits d'action c'est quoi interagit
si tu une des 40 qui a dedans avec ton
produit ou c'est les 40 qu'il y a dedans
ou c'est ce que ça marche en synergie
est-ce que oui ou non sur chaque produit
que tu prends mal savoir là exactement
ou alors à moins de faire des études
cliniques d'interactions médicamenteuse
mais qui va payer pour pour
les compagnies pharmaceutiques voudront
pas le faire c'est clair que ça a été
compagnie pas du sentier naturel les
autres les marches sont quand même assez
faibles je suis pas en train de dire
qu'ils sont dans la rue mais eux ils ont
eu ils font de la vente au volume de
faire une étude randomisée solide c'est
à double aveugle comme on dit de
tatatatatata c'est pour démontrer que
pour interaction est-ce que ça vaut la
peine il pense qu'il est vendent quand
même il est vendent quand même je sais
qu'on on va avoir de plus en plus
mais pourquoi il y a pas les mêmes
pourquoi c'est pas stricte les
réglementations
des facteurs de croissance et un facteur
de croissance sur
médicaments le casque on parle de quoi
quand on parle le facteur de croissance
des facteurs des produits biologiques
qui sont des facteurs de croissance qui
sont extraits comme des baleines exemple
de baleines des choses comme ça
mais l'histoire c'est que ces produits
là c'est pas compliqué les cosmétiques
qui vous disent on se base sur la bonne
foi des fabricants OK puis attention
dans des compagnies cosmétiques sont
absolument hallucinantes c'est propre tu
mangeras la terre il y a pas de tours
mais les critères de contrôle de la
qualité sont pas les mêmes je
m'entendais que son bon pas bon sont pas
les mêmes content de dire qu'ils sont
pas les mêmes que pour les produits
naturels que pour les médicaments
donc comment ça se fait que tu peux
avoir des produits comme ça exemple dans
du rouge à lèvres exemple il y a du
téflon des fois dans dans le vernis à
ongles elle défonce et toxiques avec les
gens qui seront les angles je sais pas
ok
mais je veux dire je peux pas avoir ces
produits là dans les médicaments
des produits dedans que tu as pas le
droit d'avoir pourquoi il y a deux
réglementations ou trois je sais pas
sauf que à mon avis c'est un peu comme
n'importe quoi il va falloir qu'il y ait
vraiment des problèmes pour que
l'argumentation encore une fois augmente
au Canada ça a changé quand même depuis
2004 il y a une division sans des Canada
avant il y en avait pas sauf que tu es
pas obligé de faire le même nombre de
tests de donner de démontrer les mêmes
innocuités profil de sécurité qu'une
molécule qui est destinée à être un
médicament puis mettons qu'on veut être
mettons qu'on va être l'avocat du diable
puisqu'on on dit qu'il y ait-on des
qu'un médicament comme un vaccin par
exemple pour être plus intrusif que
mettons du vernis à ongles tu sais
est-ce que ça peut expliquer pourquoi il
y aurait une différence entre les
différents oui aussi parce que tu
lingettes
par la voie orale on prend un cours de
bio mais tu sais c'est moins dangereux
que un être humain
[Musique]
ça se sait mais il y a pas encore assez
je pense d'urgence
pour faire ça je sais pas mais de temps
en temps on voit des tragédies là j'ai
vu un article je vais pas si longtemps
c'était
quelqu'un qui avait été il y avait été
reconnu coupable c'est parce qu'il y
avait conseillé une personne d'arrêter
son traitement
je posté d'arrêter la chimio d'arrêter
au traitement X pour sa maladie puis
remplacer ça par tel produit naturel la
personne est morte oui puis c'est ça ça
peut être tragique finalement
j'ai des collègues qui disaient leur
doctorat exemple qui était financé par
des compagnies qui viennent
d'homéopathie
puis on leur enlevé leurs bourses parce
que s'il comparais justement avec des
anticancéreux ou des choses comme ça
puis à mon avis on leur enlever leur
bourse fait que les autres ben mais mes
chats m'ont payé de leur scolarité
finalement à cause de ça l'homéopathie
aussi bon c'est une autre histoire un
peu la même chose c'est-à-dire il y a
rien de démontrer de façon
scientifique bon là c'est sûr qu'avec ce
qu'on voit sur la covid les gens vont
vous dire mais regardez même les études
qui sont faites ta tête parce que bon là
il y a beaucoup de policiers
sauf que quand tu vois une étude exemple
la covid qui est faite sur 50000
patients comme on disait ben tu as quand
même c'est un bon échantillon
si on revient à la question initiale
au départ donc vous avez comme plusieurs
molécules qui vont être testées de façon
in vitro c'est à dire sur des cellules
seulement avant d'aller chez l'animal il
y a une espèce de décrémage qui se fait
une attition naturelle qui va se faire
ensuite on va aller chez les animaux
chez des modèles animaux même qui
expriment des modèles animaux malades
puis maintenant là on est vraiment
avancé on est capable exemple d'avoir
des souris avec des poumons humains avec
un foie humain on peut faire carrément
de mettre des organes en guillemets
faire pousser des organes dans les
animaux pour avoir c'est vraiment une
espèce de que ça mime le plus possible
l'humain
puis ensuite bon ça ça représente je
dirais puis ensuite on va dire ok
il y a quelque chose
il y a des choses énormément bioéthique
ben il y a eu des problèmes de biotique
aussi avec ces nations on prend en venir
tantôt si vous voulez
c'est comme Dolly exemple la brebis qui
a été éloigné
on dit on va pas aller plus loin
je pense qu'on vient de passer une ligne
qu'on veut pas retourner
on va rouvrir une autre parenthèse parce
que parce que mettons le vaccin de la
cavité c'est que notre trame narrative
mais ça est-ce que c'est
est-ce que toutes les compagnies
pharmaceutiques les compagnies de
biotech sont transparentes c'est parce
que parce que mettons
l'impression que moi j'ai puis une
impression très peu éduquée très mal
informé juste de quelqu'un qui regarde
un peu de loin c'est qu'il y a des
affaires qui doivent se faire sans
toutes les
procédés éthiques puis ces choses-là
est-ce que je me trompe moi je pense que
votre question est très bonne quand on
voit ce qui se passe ensuite on a juste
à lire les journaux puis on voit exemple
qu'il y a des choses qui laissent
présager éventuellement qui ne sont pas
moi je pense qu'elles ont tout intérêt à
l'être pour plusieurs raisons surtout
des petites compagnies en général parce
que généralement c'est une compagnies-là
d'ailleurs il y a beaucoup d'appelés peu
d'élus ok quand vous êtes dans une
grosse compagnie vous pouvez screener
jusqu'à 10 000 molécules par année ça se
trouve il y en a aucune qui rentre
clinique parce que vous avez déjà un
portfolio puis vous en vendez déjà mais
une bibliothèque à une molécule
on parle de deux trois quatre
scientifiques dans un labo exactement
qui vont utiliser ce qu'on appelle des
compagnies de service exemple pour faire
leur test animaux pour faire le test
clinique et ainsi de suite puis ensuite
à l'internation de projet de ça mais qui
ont une molécule donc les résultats faut
qu'ils soient bons là je suis en train
de dire qu'il monte ce que je suis en
train de dire c'est qu'ils ont pas le
luxe programme elle marche pas seulement
on a comme des bakup ils ont pas ça pour
toutes sortes de raisons ils ont pas
l'infrastructure ils n'ont pas l'argent
donc c'est pour ça que il y a beaucoup
d'applis et peu d'élus ok alors qu'une
grosse compagnie comme je vous dis bon
ben et s'ils vont en screener tu as 10
000 par année ça marche pas oui ils
perdent l'argent mais ils vendent
derrière ils ont des produits ils vend
on y va on y va bientôt le taux d'échec
d'une communication est élevé lyautech
parce que la plupart vont essayer de
trouver molécules puis être rond jamais
sur 10 à une sur 50
raisons des fois d'ailleurs c'est
dommage parce que c'est pour ça que
c'est très difficile de répondre à une
question comme ça de façon
précise simplement une raison il y a
plusieurs raisons il y a des compagnies
exemples parce que les molécules étaient
prometteuses puis le bagne on s'en va
chez l'animal puis on l'animal va super
bien puis exemple au bout de deux mois
il meurent toutes
avant chien sourit
premier administration les licornes
pousses deviennent ces deux points roses
deviennent jaunes machin truc on n'a
jamais vu ça chez l'animal
aux molécules c'est sûr que maintenant
quand on regarde la structure des
molécules un peu leur empreinte on est
capable d'essayer de faire de
l'élimination parce que les molécules ça
il y a beaucoup de classes de molécules
qui se ressemblent donc les effets
secondaires aussi sont reliés un peu à
la structure ok donc on est capable des
fois aussi de prédire un peu idéalement
de prédire mais il y a aucune boule de
cristal parce que si on a une boule de
cristal on ferait même pas de recherche
on dirait regarde elle ressemble à elle
donc on a mis sur le marché là c'est
comme les médicaments génériques c'est
s'il était vraiment aussi équivalent que
les médicaments
et puis on les mettrai directement de
dollars à tester exactement
générique à mettre sur le marché c'est
quoi
par rapport à un médicament normal qui
est rendu quasiment en 2 milliard ok
fait que parce que le générique n'a pas
tout a été démontré avant tu as juste à
démontrer c'est qu'il réagit à peu près
c'est que ta concentration dans le sang
et la même que l'innovateur
effectivement
l'innovateur la copie tu prends des
volontaires surnominateur des
volontaires sur la copie tu fais des
prises de simples tu démontes que tes
profils sanguins sont les mêmes puis ben
tu es en business tu as pas besoin de
faire la Toxe
tout la toxx
en attendant ce que tu dis le présent ça
donne des arguments c'est lui qui dit
mais on a pas de boule de cristal
justement donc ce vaccin-là contre la
covid qu'est-ce qui me dit que dans 15
ans j'aurais pas telle chose qui va
apparaître c'est une excellente question
on en parle un jour un petit peu le pH
toujours au téléphone ça c'est
intéressant et ça je pense que ça amène
justement d'enlever du podcast
moi comme demande qu'est-ce qui va se
passer ma réponse est j'en ai aucune
idée
je ne le sais pas ok regardez vous
donner encore une fois encore il faut
jouer encore prendre ma grand-mère et
finalement mon meilleur volontaire
elle a pris apprenez des médicaments
pour son hypertension pendant 20 ans le
prix de même qui marchait nickel super
bien la monnaie
de médicaments bon quand tu fais ton
étude de force 3 avant d'arriver sur le
marché ok c'est à dire les phase 1
volontaires sains les phases 2 des
malades petits nombres les phases 3 des
malades grand nombre pour que ce soit
statistiquement significatif est-ce que
tout ça a été fait avec le vaccin de la
covid pas besoin de toi
c'est sûr que
une phase 3 pour médicaments
conventionnel on va venir sur la covid
aussi un mystère conventionnel mettons
ça dure à peu près mettons un an OK puis
on te demande ensuite un suivi d'un an
ok une fois que se suivit
dans le cas de la covid c'est une
pandémie mondiale
deuxième par rapport à un médicament
comme je te dis l'autre jour pour le
cholestérol qui s'adresse à une partie
ex de la population mondiale là on veut
que tout le monde soit vacciné des 10
ans mettons au 85 ans qui soit en pleine
santé qui prennent 60 et 15 médicaments
moi j'ai fait des études de phase 4 à
l'Institut cardio des gens qui prennent
médicament
si on vaccinés pareils
une population mondiale on parle de tout
le monde ok quel que soit ton origine
ethnique donc ton profil métabolique qui
change quel que soit ton état de maladie
c'est un volant c'était sain ou pas ok
vu que c'est une pandémie on a demandé
à l'époque ils ont demandé deux mois de
surveillance suivant la deuxième dose
des essais de phase 3
donc parce que c'est une pandémie
fallait aller vite il y a pas demandé
exemple un an donc oui il y a un genre
de Fastrack qui fallait faire parce
qu'on avait rien ok on avait rien c'est
aussi d'ailleurs on pourra revenir
là-dessus parce que il y a des thérapies
alors qu'un médicament conventionnel non
là ensuite vous passez de 50000 patients
pour un vaccin alors qu'un médicament
conventionnel on parle de quoi même une
force
3000 donc on a un meilleur
échantillonnage que nous disait tantôt
exemple pour un vaccin 50000 c'est
beaucoup OK puis même quand tu regardes
un peu des critères d'inclusion parce
que tu peux pas embaucher n'importe quoi
n'importe qui un vaccin tu veux
n'importe qui
faut trouver une formule qui fonctionne
avec tout le monde exactement
et tout le monde
il y a des gens exemple des fois dans
les vaccins de ce qu'on appelle des
adjuvants il y en a pas dans ceux qui à
l'heure actuelle ici il y a des gens qui
ont fait des syndromes Guilain barrés
aux adjuvants qui ont fait des grosses
réactions ok à ça il faut que tu dis ok
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour cette
population là c'est comme entre
guillemets c'était chantillionnage de
population qui est allergique à ses
composants là on dit exemple vaccin
Johnson il y a pas été commercialisé au
Canada parce que sentait le bloqué parce
qu'il paraît que dans la composition au
niveau de la qualité du produit c'est à
dire la formule la formulation en tant
que tel il y avait un produit dedans
qu'on sait pas c'est quoi il y a eu un
peu spécialiste mais qui fait en sorte
qu'ils l'ont pas mis sur le marché aux
États-Unis ok Santé Canada on dit on ne
veut pas lui un autre ils savent c'est
quoi le produit mais l'empathie
probablement ça veut dire que c'est
normal ils sont ils font juste pas dire
ces choses-là ou bien c'est l'occasion
juste pas dit que c'était ils ont juste
dit que c'est la santé des gens qui
importaient le plus puis ont raison
là-dessus si en raison à présent
qu'est-ce que c'est j'en ai aucune idée
je mettais aux États-Unis est-ce qu'on
remarque les gens vaccinés chez Johnson
Johnson il y a les effets secondaires
[Musique]
c'est plus compliqué mais je veux dire
bon pourtant il y a des vaccins qui sont
sortis c'est comme partout il y en a 250
en développement il y en a à peu près
peut-être une quinzaine de
commercialisés je parle dans le monde
c'est pas les mêmes partout là il y a
trois vaccins chinois il y a du
pique-nique le vaccin russe il y a
donc quand vous allez arriver sur le
marché ensuite maintenant ok vous avez
fait votre force 3 sur 50000 personnes
chez les virus chez les vaccins
excusez-moi puis sur quelques milliers
chez des dans un autre genre de maladie
ok là vous arrivez sur des centaines de
millions de personnes qui vont être
dosés administrer donc il y a forcément
des millions d'air des milliards dans ce
que l'on est rendu à trois points 4 je
pense pour le la covid une fois je pense
parce que non pour une fois trois points
4 vaccinés mais ça c'est des chiffres
il y a peut-être des effets secondaires
vous allez voir là qu'on a pas vu en
force 3 parce que là on pique du monde
en masse par contre ce qui est
intéressant il semblait quand on était
rendu à 400 000 au Québec d'injection je
trouvais qu'il y avait en tout cas ce
qu'on entendait il y avait moins
d'effets secondaires que la force soit
Pfizer
que dans leur étude
on dirait puis d'ailleurs encore une
fois le silo qu'il y a encore une fois
le sensationnalisme qui rentre en jeu
quand à ce que c'est l'automne dernier
quand il y a eu un arrêt de l'étude
clinique l'étude clinique de en arrêt
force 3 on est passé avec des collègues
là-dessus comment ça se fait tatata
attendez
il y en a plein de raisons là on revient
sur pour connaître un peu
de pas savoir c'est quoi moi vous savez
chaque torchon a gagné si vous me prenez
comme responsable des finances d'une
compagnie ça ferme demain c'est normal
il y a pas de problème là sauf que c'est
gros débat mais comment ça se fait que
ça a arrêté puis finalement ils ont
décidé de la reprendre comme dit que
c'est réuni regardez les effets
secondaires ils regardaient ce que c'est
du vaccin ou pas quand vous faites une
étude clinique de mettre maintenant vous
avez envie de faire une étude de Force 2
ou 3 ok c'est dans nos projets à court
terme mon frère on a fait des études moi
j'en ai fait si exemples pendant l'étude
ok tu te coupes en épluchant des patates
c'est un effet secondaire tu es obligé
de rapporter est-ce que c'est dû aux
médicaments on ne sait pas par contre
c'est arrivé pendant que tu étais sur
études donc tu te fais frapper par par
une auto
vous pouvez frapper par la fenêtre ok
merci
tu es en vélo tu tombes en vélo parce
que je sais pas moi il y avait une pure
de banane n'importe quoi c'est pas
forcément du méthan qu'on n'est pas
capable de faire cause à effet on le
rapporte ok mais la semaine suivante ou
deux semaines suivant l'arrêt de l'étude
de France 3 il y a eu un décès
je pense c'est en Amérique du Sud sur
l'étude de je sais pas si c'était sur le
fizer donc c'est pas important c'est sur
le vagin des vaccins puis on a parlé
d'une demi-journée
attention je suis en train de dire qu'il
a fait en parler pendant des mois là
c'est juste que tu sais là on a arrêté
l'étude c'était la principale sujet
comme c'est puis là qu'est-ce qu'on fait
comment ça se fait oh mon dieu ça veut
dire que s'il y a des tentacules qui
nous poussent plutôt de type ça puis en
vérité bon ils ont continué l'étude puis
deux semaines après il y a un décès où
il y a un décès puis lié au vaccin ils
savent pas on sait pas on sait pas puis
c'est comme c'est passé aux nouvelles
c'est pour ça nouvelle
c'est très très très compliqué d'avoir
une idée sur ce qui va se passer à long
terme moi c'est ce que je dis aux gens
normalement puis même un médicament
conventionnel vaccin ou pas dès qu'il
est commercialisé il faut que tu
attendes mettons deux trois ans avant
d'avoir une vraie idée c'est pour
n'importe quel n'importe quel n'importe
quel produit n'importe quel produit
mettez on s'entend
peut-être qu'on s'entend pas je sais pas
mais
c'est un risque qui est calculé au sens
où c'est pas le ratio bénéficier c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on
ignore complètement qu'on s'injecte dans
le corps qu'on sait je veux dire
exactement on a des résultats sûrement
vraiment surprenant que dans 10 ans 3.4
ou la population totale qui s'est faite
vacciner mort on est infertile tout le
monde devient fertile c'est comme
entièrement d'accord avec vous deux
l'idée c'est que ce qu'il faut pas
oublier c'est que dans le cas des
vaccins c'est une nouvelle technologie
c'est le premier ok qu'est-ce qui
explique ça pourquoi c'est le premier
qu'est-ce qui se passe
ma première réponse un drôle de mauve de
d'amener quelque chose de nouveau dans
quelque chose qu'il faut faire strike
déjà on dirait exact mais ma première
réponse ce serait parce que c'est une
pandémie
la technologie par contre a été
largement étudiée moi quand j'ai fait
mon PhD on travaille là-dessus c'est
comme c'est sur des nanous technologies
où on prenait des nanoparticules où on
mettait exemple des molécules à
l'intérieur c'est pas nouveau mais en
termes de produits sur le marché il y en
avait pas fait que là ils ont remarqué
que ça marchait très bien fait qui ont
du bingo au niveau comme ça donc ok ok
parce que ça faisait des meilleurs
résultats dans les vaccins puis qui sont
dit on veut avoir les meilleurs vaccins
possible pour arrêter la pandémie
maintenant une des raisons peut-être que
ce qui ont essayé par rapport à des
vaccins dit plus conventionnels ou
généralement on prend des virus
inactivés c'est pas le cas ici c'est pas
le cas ici il y en a il y en a le il y a
eu des vaccins chinois c'est un virus
inactivé ok
qui ont pris plus un peu comme la grippe
conventionnelle c'est la manière
standard si on veut de vaccins c'est la
manière qu'on connaissait et il y a
beaucoup de gens qui auraient aimé ça
avoir comme ça parce que ils connaissait
ça sentent plus à l'aise sauf que bon on
sait que ça marche ou que ça marche pour
prendre la grippe par exemple la grippe
dans les bonnes années ça marche à 480%
des filles est-ce qu'on a est-ce qu'on a
un pourcentage pour ces vaccins-là qui
ont été faits avec la méthode
traditionnelle ben traditionnelle avec
la méthode qu'on connaissait en Chine
les résultats encore une fois c'est
encore une fois c'est une excellente
question le jour une parenthèse
[Musique]
à l'heure actuelle quand vous regardez
tout ce qui est en communiqué de prête
aux heures maintenant quand on se parle
depuis qu'on se parle
aux heures il y a des sorties de
nouvelles études des sorties de
publication il y a des journalistes des
éditorialistes des scientifiques qui
font des montées de lait ou pas c'est
comme si qui parlent donc pour se
retrouver dans l'information c'est très
très difficile parce qu'une fois vous en
avez tellement il faut comme trier
l'information moi c'est sûr que
instinctivement je vais plus aller vers
des publications scientifiques pourquoi
parce parce que normalement les
simplifications là sont évaluées aussi
par un comité de terre
ça renforce un peu puis aussi tuer les
études c'est son soi-disant randomisés
standardisés à doubler aveugle ta ta ta
ta ta ta une rigueur scientifique parce
que des fois des journalistes ça vaut
mourir tout le monde résultat mourir
machin oui c'est correct mais c'est ça
aussi qui alimente le feu de la
compréhension et de la mauvaise même si
même pas de la non compréhension c'est
de la mauvaise aussi interprétation donc
pour en revenir à votre question quand
on regarde les études sur l'efficacité
des vaccins tu es là il disait la
variant Delta rien qu'on a actuellement
les deltaï deltopus qui sont le nouveau
variés
à 80 minutes pour ça ok société un labo
sur ce variant là oui mais attention un
labo dans le sens qu'il y a pas le temps
prend des gens qui ont qui sont
contaminés avec le delta puis de faire
une étude sur mettons 2000 personnes
dont trois en Inde deux au Japon une
enfant non ils peuvent pas ils font ce
qu'ils peuvent aussi vite qu'ils peuvent
pas donc les efficacités pour l'instant
c'est très encourageant par contre puis
ce qu'on semble remarqué entre les
profils encore une fois modifie tout le
temps ensemble parce que ça va sûrement
être infirmé demain ou après-demain ou
alors changer on dirait que les poches
de recrudescence d'épidémie sont sur les
gens non vaccinés justement je discute
avec un méchant avant-hier qui est
médecin qui urgentologue puis il me dit
à quelqu'un qui est arrivé 55 ans
d'urgence soit intensif
covidence le gars pour vacciné bon
est-ce que s'il y avait été vacciné
il serait pas rentré sur intensif on
peut penser que non parce que la
vaccination semble fonctionner à présent
est-ce que il y aurait pas fait des
effets secondaires
c'est à dire du vaccin ou de la covid
est-ce que justement la vaccination
parce que si on pourra une troisième
parenthèse un vaccin au départ là les
gens
les gens pensent que un vaccin
fonctionne un peu comme un condom
c'est à dire que tu es protégé de tout
il faut que tu es vacciné c'est comme
c'est rit plus rien te touche un vaccin
premièrement à la base de ce qu'on veut
c'est que ça t'évite de mourir ok
d'accord sa première condition la
deuxième c'est d'éviter exemple
l'hospitalisation
la troisième ça va être d'éviter les
effets secondaires qui te mènent à
l'hospitalisation la troisième c'est
d'être asymptomatique la quatrième c'est
de ne plus être contaminant bon
là les gens pensent que tu sais quand
ils vont se faire piquer avant même que
lui il rentre dans le bas sont protégés
et un condom
on a remarqué d'ailleurs il y a des
études qui ont démontré encore une fois
les chantillage moi je vous rapporte des
faits je vous dis pas que je suis
d'accord pas d'accord mais ce sont des
faits mesurés il y a eu une
recrudescence des gens postes
vaccination
si on a entendu aussi dans les journaux
avec des gens qui sont faits
dans les trois sept jours suivants ils
ont eu la covid parce que le vaccin
avait pas encore
ils sont fait tester
exemple peut-être n'était pas encore
assez sauf que tu peux être à
symptomatique si on teste
automatique on ne sait pas donc quand tu
regardes il y a des labos ils ont montré
leur courbes des gens vaccinés ou pas
parce que c'est il y a des hôpitaux
exemples où les gens reviennent c'est
exemple pour des tests
des gens vaccinés non vaccinés qui
attrape la covid après la première
vaccination et où la deuxième il y a
même des revues de presse qui ont dit
que le plus haut taux de mortalité post
première vaccination a été en Israël
et au Chili pourtant eux on sait que ça
roule hein
est-ce que c'est vrai est-ce que c'est
pas vrai je sais pas c'est des chiffres
qui ont été rapportés Israël c'est
intéressant parce que ils ont payé plus
cher leur vaccin ils l'ont dit ils ont
commencé à piquer plus tôt puis ils ont
dit ben nous on vous donne l'Israël va
vous servir c'est ils ont dit au FDA ou
FDA on vous servir de labo c'est comme
ça vous allez pouvoir prendre des
données de chez nous fait que c'est
super intéressant parce que c'est au
moins vu qu'on commençait avant qu'on
commençait justement accomplir les
résultats et tout donc c'est pour ça que
est-ce qu'on peut dire dans tel dans
tant d'années d'entendre moi ce qu'on va
voir des effets secondaires et tout je
pense je sais pas il y a le fait aussi
que par rapport par exemple un
médicament conventionnel que tu prends
exemple à tous les jours de façon
chronique pour le restant de ta vie là
c'est deux injections
le fonctionnement n'est pas le même
qu'une petite molécule c'est clair ok
parce que c'est un matériel génétique
mais t'as pas vraiment d'intoxication je
dirais par accumulation
c'est pour ça encore une fois
les études de taxe chez les animaux
quand tu développes un médicament et
commence en parallèle qui commence avant
d'aller chez l'humain tu n'as pas le
choix il faut que les résultats
d'animaux parce que ça se rapprocher du
main
mais ça dure ensuite je te dirai quand
quasiment jusqu'en début de France 3
[Musique]
quelque chose que tu vois pas là c'est
sûr encore une fois que il y a beaucoup
de gens qui ont peur parce qu'ils
disaient que c'est de la thérapie
génique la thérapie génique parce que
c'est des gènes c'est la reine c'est des
gènes
oui et non faut faire attention la
thérapie génique on est au balbutiements
de la thérapie génique pour des
problèmes de bioéthique comme vous
pouvez facilement y penser on peut pas
faire tout déterminate
parce que la thérapie génique en tant
que telle si on veut la vulgariser c'est
que exemple pH tu fais de l'asthme donc
dans ton gène dans ton ADN tu as une
section qui est pas bonne qui fait en
sorte que tu fais de l'asthme ok c'est
la délétion d'un acide aminé c'est qu'il
manque un acide aminé dans un de tes
canaux en tout cas de cellules
mais ce qu'on ferait c'est que on
t'injecterait un morceau d'ADN simple
qui code pour la faire que toi justement
peut-être pas bon on va couper ton
segment qui est pas bon on la remplace
par un morceau d'ADN 5 et pH depuis la
fibre aussi mais une fois qu'on l'a
remplacé tu es comme ça ensuite
maintenant pour le restant de ta vie
ok la techniquement les vaccins ARN on
nous pique premièrement c'est de l'ARN
l'ARN techniquement ne rentre pas dans
le noyau il y a des publications qui ont
démontré l'inverse les publications qui
ont trouvé le génome du virus qui est un
ARN du virus du sasko V2 dans le noyau
publications encore une fois je suis en
train de faire de la people
j'y crois pas ok mais c'est publié ok
donc là les gens étaient comme les
reines ça rentre pas dans l'ADN c'est
possible c'est possible comment ça se
fait c'est pas tout le monde qui a fait
ça c'est de la manipulation génétique
dans le fond oui donc ça pourrait être
une avenue mais c'est pas ça
le but là c'est que encore une fois un
vaccin normalement
c'est que tu prends la maladie atténuée
ok on va essayer de on va essayer de
vulgariser tu prends la maladie atténuée
fait que tu peux prendre le virus
atténuer ou un morceau du virus des
morceaux qu'on va appeler des antigènes
on les sépare soit on prend un virus
inactivé donc il se réactif fois dans
ton corps il y a des gens qui disent ça
peut être activé bon on va prendre donc
des débris cellulaires du virus ok on va
les injecter ton système immunitaire va
développer des anticorps et aussi des
cellules immunitaires qui vont te
protéger contre une agression
postérieur de cette maladie-là du virus
en tant que tel ok là la différence
c'est que au lieu de prendre les
antigènes directement qui sont des
protéines on voit injecter un ARN qui
est un patron qui code pour la protéine
c'est une étape d'avant et on se sert de
nos cellules pour fabriquer cette
antigène
et techniquement d'après ce qu'ils ont
dit parce que la question au moins que
je me pose depuis le début c'est l'ARN
justement qu'on nous injecte l'ARN il
reste combien de temps il reste combien
de temps il reste combien de temps il
reste pas longtemps ok
efficace comme temps encore une fois
excellente question avant-hier il y a eu
un pressualis
que deux injections de phase 2
finalement fonctionneraient sur
plusieurs années ouais j'ai vu ça est-ce
que c'est vrai ce que c'est pas vrai
c'est sûrement vrai par rapport aux
résultats
de l'étude à présent ont même pas encore
plusieurs années
du virus dans le corps d'une personne
comment ça se fait parce que la personne
est arrivée en disant d'ailleurs
parenthèse je me sens pas bien il y
avait déjà eu la copie d'une fois
puis il y avait les mêmes symptômes
cliniques ouais il y avait les mêmes
scènes ton cliniques la cliente
aussi on lui a fait un test rien
on lui a fait un test de sang ils
regardent encore mais les anticorps sont
pas discriminatoires c'est pas parce que
tu as des anticorps que tu défends
contre la covid il y a eu des tests qui
ont été faits il y a des gens qui ont
été avec tous les vaccins
qui ont été on a fait des sérologies
pour voir cette développer des handicaps
contre la covid il y a des gens qui ont
très peu puis ça veut pas dire que c'est
un autre que tu défendras pas il y a des
gens qui ont été asymptomatiques avec
ou presque ok il y en a qui ont été
hyper malades avec plein dans ce corps
mais donc quand on parle du taux
d'efficacité du vaccin encore une fois
que c'est un peu de trompeur parce que
c'est pas ça marche ça marche pas c'est
que la covid votre frapper moins fort ou
ça sera pas différent exactement sans
encore une fois une excellente question
j'écoutais un peu un paquet de
scientifique si c'est la planète qui
parlait de suite c'est des sur
l'efficacité 80% 90 %, on s'en fout là
faut regarder comment est évalué si le
fait est si tu évalue sur le fait que tu
prends 100 personnes sur vaccin sans
personne sur un placebo
sur le placebo puis mettons 5 sur le
vaccin
mais que tes critères c'est juste de
dire ils sont cliniquement corrects
[Musique]
symptomatique est-ce que tu l'as eu
quand même comme on disait tantôt tu
peux l'avoir et être symptomatique
tu peux contaminer quelqu'un je veux
dire symptomatique mais si tu me touches
dans la phase de quelqu'un qui est pas
vacciné d'ailleurs ça aussi ça a été
démontré quelqu'un qui est vacciné ou
pas qui est assez sympatique sur la
covid a le même nombre de virus dans son
arbre bronchial c'est à dire bouche
poumons
c'est une des plus grandes confusions en
ce moment est-ce que est-ce que le fait
d'avoir été vacciné je peux lui donner
quand même est-ce que petit faisait la
liste des pays on n'est pas on n'est pas
arrêté sur ce point là mais je trouve ça
vraiment intéressant de parce que c'est
ça les grands questionnements j'ai
l'impression puis les grandes confusions
c'est comme c'est une excellente
question que tu as posé encore une fois
vous posez vraiment des super bonnes
questions c'est génial non mais c'est
parce que c'est
on a rien ce qu'on disait tantôt moi je
vais appliquer ça bêtement et simplement
puis attention je suis pas clinicien je
suis pas virologue je suis pas
imminologue je suis pas je suis pas en
train de dire je suis rien mais je suis
pas j'ai pas une notoriété comme exemple
le professeur Raoul la famille
professionnel
mais je veux dire mais moi je suis un
scientifique de salon
mais il y a l'étude là
ou des vaccins ça dit deux infections
fait que il te faut deux injections
OK et dans deux trois ans quand tout ça
sera compilé là on va être capable de
dire ah tiens une injection était
suffisante matière finalement ils ont
dit Astro zenico oui hier c'est
finalement 45 semaines entre les deux
injections c'est ce que donner de
meilleurs résultats bon faites-le ça
veut dire quoi les gens qui ont eu comme
deux mois c'est pas bon
le protocole de l'étude clinique disait
deux injections je pense séparer trois
ou quatre semaines ma mère est en France
était vaccinée deux fois à 4 semaines
intervalle ici c'est plus par contre
parce qu'ici on a encore une fois
excellent point ici on a capitalisé sur
on va piquer tout le monde une fois le
plus en France on dit non on pique deux
fois puis là d'ailleurs ils ont commencé
de même après ils ont continué à vouloir
piquer le plus de monde tout le monde
finalement est en train de rattraper un
peu sauf les pays qui dépendent la
covacs ça c'est un autre problème aussi
parce que même si le Canada
si moi je suis vacciné deux fois je vais
dans un pays où est-ce que mettons un
pays imaginaire ou est-ce que personne
ne vacciner je pourrais aller là puis
donner à tout le monde pareil si si tu
es assez
automatiquement c'est possible par
contre moins de chance
ça dépend de toi finalement
oui techniquement est-ce que ça diminue
les chances quand même de le transmettre
où on sent on sait pas on va dire oui
parce que exemple si tu as symptomatique
tu vas pas tousser
ces choses-là par contre je sais pas moi
c'est comme si tu nettoies pas les mains
puis que c'est des poignées de porte
c'est je sais pas au moitié des petits
nettoie les mains aussi souvent que par
rapport à des gens qui sont qui sont pas
vacciner
oui
donc techniquement tu vas moins
projeté de particules
pour ça que il y a pas de demi-mesure
dans ce moment c'est même on est vacciné
deux fois on continue même un masque
[Musique]
c'est ça puis le type parce que là
depuis tantôt on parle puis s'il y a
beaucoup d'incertitudes moi parce que je
peux pas répondre précisé
pour n'importe qui qui écoute qui entend
ça n'importe qui en fait qui suit un peu
au courant de se dire ok une nouvelle
technologie
pas d'études sur le long terme non
processus accéléré
pourquoi est-ce que de 1 c'est ça a été
le ratio risque bénéfice pour ça c'est à
quel point c'est positif puis de deux
est-ce que maintenant mettons est-ce que
avec
commençons par la première question puis
reste là c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'il
faut se faire vacciner maintenant
du succès de ça puis pourquoi est-ce que
le risque de développer quelque chose
sur le long terme et minime le
comparativement à où est-ce que c'est
minime bonne question moi je pense que
c'est minime à présent peut-être que
dans un an vous allez me rappeler ici en
disant regarde j'ai une tentacule qui
m'a poussé puis là je
suis à la pourquoi vous dire je pense
que les risques féminine parce que bon
il y a quand même aussi des études qui
ont été faites je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est sur les animaux bon les
animaux ne sont pas les humains je suis
d'accord mais il y a quand même il y a
pas rien non plus ok on a quand même des
études cliniques qui ont été faits de
phase 1 2 et 3 sur plusieurs populations
plusieurs tranches d'âge ok on voit
exemple que le taux d'hospitalisation
est beaucoup plus faible
on voit que les personnes âgées décèdent
beaucoup moins malgré les langues sales
qui vont dire que c'est normal vu que
ceux qui devaient décéder sont déjà
mortes je suis pas capable d'entendre ça
mais je l'ai entendu trop souvent donc
moi je pense que oui il y a un net
avantage ok on le voit c'est clair
mais répondre à la question qu'est-ce
qui va se passer dans un an et demi
soyons positifs et disons qu'il devrait
pas se passer grand chose il y a des
gens qui est-ce que quand même
de l'optimisme par rapport au fait que
va rien se passer bien sûr si j'imagine
parce que j'imagine que toutes les
scientifiques qui travaillent sur ça sur
les vaccins qu'ils ont développé les
tests tout j'imagine qu'il y a rien qui
indique qui aurait des complications que
d'autres vaccins il y a quand même suivi
sur les 3 milliards de personnes qui
sont vaccinées à l'heure actuelle
[Musique]
c'est quand même prometteur à date il y
a pas de c'est un peu comme c'est un peu
comme la question avec les thromboses
avec l'astrazeneca
je veux dire
le ratio encore une fois
eminemment
plus de chance de faire une thrombose
prendre l'avion juste prendre l'avion
vous avez plus de chance de faire une
pause ainsi de suite ma sœur le prix ma
sœur était dans la tranche puis ma sœur
va super bien le prix des deux doses
station c'est ma sœur il y a eu des
décès c'est un décès de trous c'est
absolument regrettable ok c'est vraiment
regrettable c'est pas normal mais c'est
beaucoup moins de
100 vaccination je pense que oui
définitivement on le voit là on le voit
et c'est ce qui va permettre de
retourner éventuellement à une vie
normale à présent la vaccination n'est
pas la seule chose à souligner
je pense qu'on ne parle pas assez des
traitements à l'hôpital
[Musique]
ça serait une pilule plus une fois que
tu l'as tu prends ça parce que ça va
devenir un guillemets un peu comme une
grippe ce serait chez vous
ta charge est moins grande virale dans
le sang et
puis j'imagine que des études pour des
choses comme ça en ce moment il y en a
plein oui il y en a plein je pourrais
aussi dire que vous avez entendu parler
probablement d'études qui ont eu un
essai cardio ça colchicine non c'est
quelque chose de bien ça parce que bon
ça c'est un peu pour apprendre ce que
disent beaucoup de gens
il y a probablement avec le nombre
médicament qu'on a sa planète il y en a
sûrement qui existe qui pourrait aider
bon il y a des droits il y a des gens
qui ça marche des gens qui disent ça
marche pas on a entendu des choses
absolument aberrantes c'est quand même
un médicament qui est pris par plus de 2
milliards de personnes par jour
2 millions de personnes par jour oui
c'est un anti-malarien pour le paludisme
en Afrique qui entraîne depuis que son
nez moi il me dit moins fixe j'ai pas
que ça comme des smarties depuis que je
suis né
aussi l'hiver mectain qui est utilisé
qui est un aspirateur
donnait en conjoint avec la dystomycine
puis encore une fois je suis pas médecin
je suis pas en train de faire des
posologie je suis en train de faire des
prescriptions mais bon la mémoire tu ne
faculté qui oublie bon
l'hydroxyloroquine a été vraiment
démonisée dans tout ce qui est continent
américain Europe et alors que c'est
utilisé en Asie à fond moi je suis en
train de dire que ça marche ça marche
pour tout ce que je sais c'est qu'il y a
265 études qui ont été publiées qui
disent que les racines semblent
fonctionner
ok
265 études bon là il y a des gens qui
vont dire est-ce que ces études-là sont
bonnes mais versus combien qui disent
que ça va que des résultats dans l'autre
sens que ça change rien en fait ça je
peux pas vous dire sauf que c'est un peu
comme ça je sais pas quoi sur les 265
sont toutes mauvaises c'est un peu comme
si vous me disiez moi j'ai mes étudiants
des fois qui me rendent des travaux j'ai
100 fautes d'orthographe OK puis il me
dit oui
[Musique]
méthode de 165
mais à date ce qui se passe c'est que
tout ce qu'on a dit
il y a de plus en plus de pays en tout
cas asiatiques africain qui utilisent
pour la copine pour la covid et ça ça
fonctionne mais attention encore une
fois lorsque je ne rapporte que des
faits encore une fois je suis pas
clinicien ça fait beaucoup médicamenter
mais ça dépend aussi du stade
visiblement quand tu commences à le
donner
exemple une covid forte trop tard ça
arrive c'est fait il y a vraiment un
diagnostic clinique à faire à l'avance
visiblement d'après ce que les
publications donnent fait qu'il y a des
cas où ça ne sert à rien la College
piscine c'est une étude qui vient de
cardio de Montréal docteur
[Musique]
US entre autres et pour ça où est-ce que
je vais en venir c'est qu'encore une
fois on en revient un peu ce que je
disais tout à l'heure ce sont des
médicaments qui sont génériques ok
oubliez le fait que ça marche ça marche
pas sur le médicament générique la
colchicine ça existe depuis une éternité
l'hydroxyloquine ces années 60 peut être
même 50
est-ce qu'il y a des compagnies qui sont
prêtes à mettre de l'argent là-dedans
pour faire des vraies études c'est
solides parce que les études cliniques
des 265 que je vous parlais c'est
surtout des études cliniques de
médecins traitant ok donc c'est pas
genre une compagnie qui dit ben moi je
mets du cash dans le cherokeen puis je
fais une étude énorme sur 50000
personnes ces gens parce que pourquoi
parce que en guillemets il y a beaucoup
de gens qui vont dire ben parce que pas
d'argent à faire ces médicaments
s'il y a une possibilité que de vendre
ça par tout sa planète
encore une fois je sais que ce que je
viens de dire c'est facile à dire c'est
plus compliqué que c'est comme quelqu'un
est ciseaux là c'est clair là c'est
comme ça c'est pas comme ça sauf que moi
je pense que regarder bien on utilise la
dexaméthasone qui est un ancien
inflammatoire pour la covid justement
pour ceux qui font l'inflammation au
poumon à mort c'est utilisé ça semble
fonctionner mais ça c'est pour des cas
grave c'est comme c'est la tempête de
stocker
ils peuvent donner aussi des cortico
stéroïdes qui sont des anciens
inflammatoires puissants ce souci c'est
un vieux médicament qui existe mais
est-ce qu'il y a des études sérieuses
qui sont en train d'être faites sur ces
médicaments là
[Musique]
de commencer une grosse étude clinique
sur un de ceux qui te nommé que j'oublie
le nom
ça
se passe en ce moment il y a des études
qui sont faites c'est pris au sérieux
quand même oui tout à fait parce que
c'est on a dit ce qu'on entend
maintenant le temps aussi il y a quand
même un courant
dans le Dark web de de dire que on
essaie de taire puis de censurer ceux
qui proposent justement des alternatives
comme ça
par sous prétexte qu'il y a pas d'études
sérieuses qui sont faits mais c'est pas
vrai il y a des c'est pris au sérieux
c'est ces alternatives-là une excellente
question moi je pense que les études en
tout cas justement les 260 j'ai pas lu
les 265 mais j'en ai une coupe c'est des
études puis encore une fois je suis pas
clinicien mais je veux dire c'est qu'ils
sont fait selon les règles dollars tu
auras jamais une étude sur 100 millions
de personnes maintenant ça arrive au
fait que ton échantillonnage sera
peut-être pas statistiquement
représentatif d'une population mondiale
ok je veux dire on a vu exemple quand en
Afrique il y a beaucoup moins de décès
le continent africain que exemple
Amérique du Nord on dirait que les
continents très industrialisés en ont
mangé toute une question de comment les
chiffres sont rapportés
africains j'en ai beaucoup qui m'ont dit
la covidence
[Musique]
des personnes qui en prennent par jour
il y aurait 200 millions de personnes
qui mourraient par jour je pense qu'on
le saurait s'il y avait 200 millions de
personnes qui meurent
fallait pas en prendre que c'est
cardio-taxique là ils ont fait une étude
justement contre des CV qui est un autre
médicament qui a été essayé un antiviral
qui était à l'origine pour ébolo ici de
contre ça puis on a l'étude vient de
sortir en disant que non c'est la reine
des CV qui est cardio-toxique qui est
polydroxyloroquine sauf qu'encore une
fois c'est une étude qui à mon avis est
faite bien parce que les résultats il
faut les regarder là
vous disent des choses c'est pas des
discussions de balle on prend une
question
faut regarder comment ça a été fait faut
regarder les protocoles expérimentaux
faut regarder tout ça fait que c'est à
peu près ça mais n'empêche que tu sais
mettons en ce moment sur le vaccin
personnes mais là en ce moment il y a la
moitié de la planète finalement qui
était piquée c'est qu'on appelle les
études de pharmacovigilance sur la
population en ce moment je veux dire
c'est pas une étude mais c'est juste on
pique le monde puis la moitié de la
planète est piqué puis il y a pas c'est
pas les cartons bleus je n'ose pas ça se
passe bien tout à fait ça se passe très
bien c'est pour ça je disais même tantôt
on aurait dit qu'il y avait moins de ou
alors si ça a été plus rapporté pour les
petites cliniques
mais c'est moi j'entends oui des gens
vous avez sûrement des collègues des
amis qui ont été vaccinés avec la
troisième école qui ont été peut-être un
peu plus mâchées à la première injection
moi ma sœur elle m'a dit c'est la
première érection genre petit bouillon
de poulet petit frissons grippe
couverture un petit peu 24 heures la
deuxième rien moi je sais que ma
deuxième injection là j'ai eu un peu de
fatigue je pense je dormais plus plus
longtemps
je trouve que d'appeler ça d'appeler ça
et fait secondaire je trouve ça
c'est la sensation d'avoir mal dans le
brasciner
ça moi je dis toujours ça le à chaque
fois que chaque fois je me fais vacciner
c'est le même feeling qui a craqué
d'aller au gym puis tu viens de faire
des épaules le métier fait que si tu te
fais vacciner
mal au bras genre mal au bras c'est
comme tout était raquié des jeux parce
que moi c'est ma vie au complet mais
j'aime se sentent comme ça 24 heures sur
c'est ça pour vrai tu sais c'est des
effets secondaires on s'entend que c'est
pas si c'est ça le pire qu'on va avoir
avec le vaccin on s'entendais sont très
fort mais aussi c'est ça quand tout le
monde dit la deuxième dose à frappe la
deuxième dose à frappe ça se peut que la
deuxième dose ça te frappe il y a des
gens qui vont dire c'est 40 %
typique les médicaments c'est 50% de
l'efficacité il fait placer sur une
planète j'ai discuté mais je me rappelle
on avait assisté à des conférences il y
a des gens qui disaient ça c'est vrai
d'ailleurs qu'un médicament c'est
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça exemple que
exemple pour le cholestérol ben vous ça
va être un tel puis vous vivez un autre
parce que vous vous acceptez pas celui
qui prend vous êtes moins tolérants de
médicaments adaptés aux gens mais là le
vaccin les bus toujours de battre le
placebo dans le fond c'est ça que si
jamais tu es pas supérieur ou placé beau
ça va pas bien
ça va vraiment pas médicament très
efficace
c'est que sur les études cliniques qui
sortent pour les nouveaux vaccins et on
a de la difficulté à recruter pourquoi
parce qu'il existe maintenant des
vaccins contre la
covidence exactement les populations en
Suisse intéressante c'est à dire qu'ils
sont plus sensibles plus âgés ont déjà
été vaccinés deux fois et puis ils
veulent pas faire partie d'une autre
étude ceux qui sont pas vacciner parce
qu'ils veulent pas
d'ailleurs c'est d'ailleurs c'est à
cause de ça probablement qu'on va avoir
plusieurs je peux entrer une critiquer
les antivax là bon on peut les critiquer
ce qu'on voit c'est les poches
visiblement de recrudescence à l'heure
actuelle qui remonte c'est ceux qui sont
pas vacciner en Angleterre ils ont été
vacciné astrozeneca
160% deux fois les poches justement les
autres sont à 20 000 cas par jour là
puis ça semble être bon encore une fois
c'est de l'information c'est du
passionné j'ai pas les vrais chiffres ça
semble être les gens qui sont pas
vaccinés donc la solution à court terme
c'est vacciner tout le monde c'est ça le
problème parce qu'on dirait que c'est
tellement une
décision individuelle mais en même temps
c'est tellement collectif comme décision
au sens aussi parce que j'entendais un
biologiste
j'entendais un biologiste sur
l'évolution qui est spécialisée sur
l'évolution qui disait que les virus
plus ils ont du temps à se développer à
évoluer plus amener le vaccin il servira
plus à rien là-dessus ils vont muter ils
vont notre génome mais constitué de
vieux restants de virus de plusieurs
générations ton ADN il y a à peu près
20% de tes gènes c'est des vieux c'est
comme qui sont transmis depuis
génération génération
le virus aussi un virus pas compliqué ça
veut contaminer un virus un parasite ok
il reste chez une espèce tant qu'il peut
te contaminer il peut pas imite il peut
plus il change d'espèces
plus tu défends plus mute c'est logique
avec les variantes de dire exemple comme
on disait tantôt exemple
c'est comme plusieurs années parfait
sauf que c'est un vrai variant là il va
il va s'enlever
différents ou ton vaccin n'est pas
efficace ça fait comme la grippe c'est
ça c'est la grippe des fois ça marche
des fois
que les gens qui décident de pas se
faire vacciner puis continuer à propager
ce virus là puis à l'aider à se
transformer puis ça va faire
qu'éventuellement tous ceux qui ont pris
la décision d'aller se faire vacciner
pour le bien de s'en sortir vont se
ramasser avec un Variant qui répond plus
aux vaccins exactement
je comprends aussi il y a des gens c'est
comme parce que c'est démontré comme
dans l'histoire que c'est quand à peu
près 75 80% des mobilisation
tu peux tu peux endiguer c'est comme ça
moi exemple
se fait vacciner je voyais l'école de
mon fils c'était
comme l'école bon ils obligeront jamais
à signer par contre ils peuvent très
bien dire bien sûr ils sont pas vaccinés
c'est exemple si le 75 % de doses
comme tout le monde veut comme pour
l'ouverture de la frontière exemple ben
tu vas suivre tes cours à distance
peut-être oblige pas de vacciner
mais c'est un peu comme Jean pile je
gagne et face super c'est un peu
le choix mais je pense que c'est une
bonne chose de le faire parce que sinon
on va se ramasser avec puis justement
cette personne là que j'ai écouté qui
disait que
que si on agissait pas si on atteignait
pas l'immunité rapidement on pouvait
être pris avec ça pour le reste de notre
vie la covid puis la covid quand même un
virus qui est destructeur comme on le
connaît maintenant et qui pourrait muter
jusqu'à l'être encore plus exactement
puis l'affaire c'est que une grippe
mauvaise année au Canada si vous avez 6
à 8000 morts par année puis on est déjà
à 11000 juste au Québec pour la covid
donc c'est pas une grippe
en plus c'est qu'on a la grippe qu'on
est à 8000 morts on a aucune mesure pour
pour essayer de l'attirer on met pas de
masque contre la pointe à l'épicerie
puis là on est à 11000 morts pour c'est
comme si on c'est comme si on disait il
y a plus de monde qui meurent ça à route
mais c'est comme si on disait ok on
arrête de prendre nos chars les morts sa
route vont descendre
recrudescence justement aux États-Unis
il y a une stagnation au niveau des
contaminations
baisser c'est dans les étoiles sont pas
vaccinées et aussi il y a une
recrudescence de grippe du rotavirus
c'est-à-dire être des gastro parce que
les gens ont envie de masques
c'est comme là la grippe pour
éventuellement revenir deuxièmement
parce que il y avait peur il y avait du
monde sur la grippe ça aurait été
l'enfer de revenir finalement de la peau
le masque je pense beaucoup beaucoup
aidé moi je pense sérieusement même que
je pense que tu as plus de risques
d'attraper une gastro en allant faire
ton marché de fruits légumes
[Musique]
faire
il y a des places où est-ce que je vais
garder le masque mais il y a des
affaires tu sais
juste
rencontrer quelqu'un puis donner des
becs ça n'arrivera plus que je refasse
ça c'est déjà que ça me rendait
inconfortable d'entrée de jeu ensuite un
gâteau de fête dans un bar boire dans le
verre de quelqu'un d'autre plus jamais
faire ça déjà que ça maquillera un peu
plus jamais faire ça
mais peut-être que justement on sait pas
vraiment comment ça va se passer avec le
temps est-ce que il y a beaucoup de gens
qui s'entendent pour dire que si
justement la virulence va baisser puis
il faut devenir un peu comme la grippe
c'est à dire que tu ça va être un parce
que la grippe espagnole d'accord
des gens mais c'est beaucoup moins
c'est vert
ou d'un paquet d'affaires ou c'est des
restaurants parce que c'est ça peut
imiter ça l'affaire ça peut muter avec
dans cette salle ici là dans une salle
vous êtes agressé par jour à peu près
par 800 particules là je parle
qualitative en vérité on a des millions
mais 800 à peu près on va dire
particules différentes qui nous agresse
le micro-agression
[Rires]
mais on est resté militaire
tu peux avoir aussi des mutations qui la
mutation est pas nécessairement de virus
à virus ou de scie à ça ou de un paquet
de brassage et une soupe qui se fait
probablement qu'avec le temps ça devrait
baisser de virulence en tout cas c'est
ce qu'on veut parce que là tout le monde
dit on a le vaccin c'est beau
oui c'est beau c'est un excellent outil
pour nous aider à faire baisser ça puis
à reprendre une vie on va dire à peu
près normale mais par contre il y aura
pas un autre variant après Delta ça va
être quoi
par rapport à aux gens qui refusent de
faire vacciner toutes sortes de raisons
mais souvent
on a parlé un petit peu plus tôt
rapidement mais si il y a une espèce de
liens en toute sorte de théories
mettons qui englobe tout plein
d'affaires dont une méfiance un refus du
vaccinct puis il y a plein d'affaires
puis là on en parle plein de fois qu'on
sait pas sur le vaccin pour la fin qu'on
sait pas sur le vaccin à long terme mais
je m'imagine qu'il est aussi pleine
affaire qu'on sait très bien puis que
dans ces espèces d'information
alternative là fausse finalement
va injecter
[Musique]
la
résistance au vaccin à l'excitait déjà
avant la copine et puis je pense que
c'est dans les années 80 années qui
avait eu une étude une fois qui faisait
un lien entre le vaccin puis l'autisme
ça avait été
démonté ça avait été prouvé qu'il y
avait puis mais c'était comme c'est
comme c'était resté dans l'imaginaire
des gens qui a qui est le vaccin peut
causer de développer des affaires
ce type de problème là
pourtant c'est démontré quand vous
regardez dans l'histoire de la
vaccination sauve des vies mais oui ça
on n'a pas vu de choses comme ça
suite à au vaccin là
ok si c'était le exemple on a dit fizer
j'ai vu une étude
qu'elle phase 2
après ça deuxième vaccination un
collègue une zone les deux vacciné
est-ce que là je suis prêt à dire que
c'est obligatoirement
non par contre j'ai vu une étude sur 600
patients
300 places
les six quand on va la randomisation
les six qui ont fait le zona c'était des
gens vaccinés bon est-ce que un lien
causes à effet c'est sûr que c'est 6 sur
600 ça fait 1%
c'est énorme
[Musique]
où est-ce que je vais en venir t'en
prendre en laisse il faut attendre il
faut attendre pour avoir plus de données
dans le fond il faut attendre moi quand
j'étais petit les huiles c'était l'enfer
fallait pas boire maintenant l'huile
d'olive il faut que tu en boives des
litres
[Rires]
mais l'avant c'est ça parce que faut
attendre pour plus de données sur un
million d'affaires mais la seule affaire
qu'on s'est réellement tangiblement
maintenant c'est que c'est ça qui nous a
permis de sauver des millions de villes
exactement
c'est ça ils sont aussi directement puis
là c'est des discussions que j'ai
souvent exemple quand j'allais chercher
mon fils à l'école quand il était plus
petit parce que des parents qui sont
antivaxes c'est corrects
je suis désolé ça sauve des vies moi
c'est sûr dans mon temps un montant
grise
il y avait pas ces vaccins
mais moi sans dire que je suis provacs
je suis pas antivax loin de là tu as
besoin d'un traitement fais-le les
médicaments si tu en as besoin prend les
bon là on pourrait faire partir un autre
débat qui durait plus qu'une heure et
demie sur la surconsommation médicament
ça c'est sûr que ça existe il y a des
gens aussi
les interactions
qui prend son cocktail le matin et son
brunch à chaque matin tu sais les
interactions en toute ces médicaments-là
je me rappelle plus qu'on parlait dessus
qui disait que finalement dans ces
médicaments là ça se peut qu'il y en a
qui tire plus à rien parce qu'ils
interagissent pas que les autres
directement
dans l'alimentation il y a des
médicaments c'est qu'il faut pas un
exemple c'est que du lait ou tu prennes
avec la nourriture ou pas
c'est juste des gars parce qu'il est
débile d'accord ça s'adresse à une
population ok on prenait juste des gars
c'est débile c'est normal parce qu'il
voulait minimiser les variabilités
volontaire simple c'est pas de pression
pas de cholestérol absolument rien rien
rien rien rien rien rien sur ton test
alright
c'est beau ça a la population après deux
c'est pas du tout ces gens qui prennent
des médicaments
depuis 72 heures d'alcool de machin truc
chouette les gens ils prennent ça le
matin subit tapis de gym avec du scotch
avec du café avec des toasts avec la
salade ah j'ai oublié mes médicaments
mais la façon que c'est fait qui est
vraiment c'est pas de bouc dans la vraie
vie c'est possible
du tout du tout puis pourtant ça marche
ça semble marcher
mais je suis pas en train de dire aussi
qu'il faudrait que ce soit free for all
pendant les études non plus mais c'est
pour ça qu'il faut en prendre et à
laisser mais c'est un domaine comme vous
avez dit messieurs très bien où on sait
pas tout puis surtout surtout avec avec
maintenant la covid qui est de nouveau
là on sait pas ouais puis et où on
s'arrête éventuellement encore une fois
je pense beaucoup plus aux sensations
on parle de quoi oh ça marche
on parle de puis c'est un peu ça qui qui
est dommage parce que moi je pense qu'il
faudrait continuer à matraquer
l'information que la vaccination
Overlord comme on vient de dire c'est
bon ça sauve des vies puis que c'est
avec ça qu'on à l'heure actuelle c'est
les armes qu'on a la vaccination les
thérapies cliniques sont utilisées
c'est pas dire qu'on va pas pouvoir
trouver justement un médicament
alternatif qu'on utilisait pour autre
chose éventuellement avoir des études
qui m'ont prouvé que ça fonctionne c'est
vraiment excellent mais comme je vous
dis faudrait faire les études pour ça
il faut développer l'argent pour les
sens exactement une pièce qui a des
compagnies vont vouloir le faire
embarquer là-dedans ce serait une
excellente chose
ça vient tout d'Angleterre l'Angleterre
nous disait comment faire mais c'est eux
qui ont les plus haut taux de
contamination mais c'est comme des hauts
taux de mortalité et tout c'est un peu
comme coronavirus finalement
standardisation protocole le problème
avec le vaccin c'est qu'on dirait que
quand ça fonctionne on n'envoie plus
l'utilité
ma grand-mère biologique c'est que j'ai
pas connu un mot de la polio le 60 ans
qui fait que maintenant justement c'est
plus
c'est plus un danger le mourir de la
polio vraiment pour nous autres
mais
factice c'est comme si c'était plus un
danger mais même chose pour la covid
j'ai l'impression que toi quelqu'un qui
se dit il y a presque plus de fini la
covid
75 % fait que on est quasiment là j'ai
plus besoin c'est comme je pense que ma
née il y avait eu une
hausse dans les cas de
parce que justement comme c'était de
moins en moins
communs
on
se prépare pas si on fait pas attention
à l'inverse exemple qui vivent avec la
tuberculose
puis eux ils vont les résultats de covid
qui sont pour eux c'est comme c'est
quasiment moi j'ai entendu des pays dire
c'est un virus de pacotille c'est une
mauvaise la tuberculose
dangereuse puis c'est comme qui nous
fait rentrer à l'hôpital plus puis fait
que ça aussi le problème c'est de faire
accepter ça au niveau mondial aussi
encore une fois c'est du 2 vitesses les
pays de la coaxe moi celui-là doivent se
faire vacciner regarder l'Inde
avant qu'on termine je vais parler moi
je suis je suis vegan dans ville puis je
veux parler parce que c'est quelque
chose qui me
qui me tiraille beaucoup à l'intérieur
les tests sur animaux parce qu'on en
parlait tout à l'heure qui des fois ça
sonne comme comme un cauchemar tu sais
les images qu'on a des fois puis est-ce
que il y a parce que
je suis je suis tiraillé au niveau de
quand c'est nécessaire absolument est-ce
qu'il y a des tests qui sont faits sur
les animaux c'est juste par parce que
moi j'ai entendu ça quand même du
discours de militants vegan c'est ce qui
est des tests sur animaux qui sont
faites juste parce que c'est dans la
culture de recherche pharmaceutique de
faire des tests alors qu'on pourrait les
faire sur
des en labo le tu sais sur des cellules
qui seraient semblables à celle des
animaux c'est déjà fait mais est-ce
qu'il y en a encore qui se fait des
tests pas essentiels sur des animaux à
mon avis bon encore une fois je suis pas
toxicologue je fais pas mal d'études de
textes mais je peux toxicologue
moi je pense que non non
mais déjà exemple je sais que chez le
singe il y a carrément des sortes de
singes qui ont été interdites
d'utilisation alors qu'avant il y en
avait beaucoup plus
donc on essaie vraiment de minimiser
aussi le nom le nombre d'espèces
et aussi c'est pas bon ça veut dire des
animaux ce sont des animaux mais les
animaux de laboratoire sont élevés pour
les laboratoire
c'est pas séquence finitude chez le
chien tu prends pas des chiens
on doit être capable de retrouver
directement il y a aussi un avantage de
le faire sur des lignées comme ça sur
des lignées c'est que tu connais
vraiment la descendance complète de A à
Z fait qu'il y aura pas une aberration
exemple d'une génération qui
transportait un gène mauvais puis qui
l'a fait passer à tout le monde et que
tu as moins de biais mais les cellules
c'est déjà utilisé chez les cellules le
problème d'une cellule c'est que c'est
bien beau mais généralement c'est ce
qu'on appelle in vitro il y a une vidéo
ça marche tout le temps
ouais ça marche tout le temps très bien
exactement un métier en gros
pour cellules sont comme ça toutes les
asperges avec ton médicament j'aimerais
ça d'écrire pour les gens qui écoutent
juste qui voient pas j'ai de la réserver
une assiette mais attends c'est un peu
dedans c'est un morceau de tissu on va
dire des cellules et tu verse ton
médicament exemple en solution exemple
dans l'eau directement sur tes cellules
ça rentre entre guillemets directement
dedans alors que quand tu prends un
médicament par la bouche par exemple
mais il faut que tu lavalles si c'est un
comprimé il faut qu'il se désintègre il
faut que ça passe dans l'estomac dans
l'estomac de l'acide il y a des enzymes
tu peux commencer à dégrader ton
médicament ensuite ça passe dans
l'intestin tiens ça passe un autre pH
c'est l'estomac c'est assez l'intestin
non tu as une fleur bactérienne c'est un
paquet il y a un paquet de portes que tu
dois passer comme tu as dit tantôt
ensuite tu peux avoir c'est des
interactions croisées ça peut aller
ailleurs
c'est fait en gros tu en prends une
louche dans ta bouche puis tu en as un
grain qui arrive à ta cible parce que ça
va être absorber en circulation sanguine
puis ensuite il faut savoir jusqu'à
mettons l'endroit où tu as mal dit
l'endroit où ça doit agir
la cellule seulement c'est pas suffisant
tu as pas d'intégration métabolique
puis même il y a des gens qui vont dire
que les souris c'est des cellules avec
des pâtes parce que c'est pas un modèle
qui est spécialement complexe complexe
alors que pourtant il y a des très bons
modèles qu'on dit muret souris de souris
qu'on est capable de refaire avec comme
je disais tantôt des organes humains
il y a des gens qui vous disent qu'il y
a une corrélation à peu près de 30%
entre la souris et l'homme
moi personnellement je trouve que non
mais ça c'est un autre débat je me
rappelle j'étais dans une compagnie
demandé on avait testé un médicament sur
quatre espaces animales différentes à la
même dose pour la même indication puis
on avait 4 résultats complètement
différents
[Musique]
on s'envoie d'ailleurs sur de la
médecine personnalisée on déborde la
question mais on s'en va sur de la
médecine personnalisée parce que les
médicaments sont faits pour une moyenne
de gens sauf que maintenant ce qu'on
veut carrément c'est d'être capable de
te donner un médicament en fonction de
ton profil métabolique de ton origine
ethnique à cause de ton métabolisme
c'est ton phénotype c'est exemple les
gens qui ont un phénotype mettons
n'importe quoi
peut-être que cette personne là pour tel
type de maladie réagit différemment
qu'une autre personne qui a la même
maladie
je pense qu'on s'en sortira pas de le
faire au niveau cellulaire avant au
niveau animal ensuite parce que à moins
que on accepte d'aller directement ouais
c'est ça sur l'humain c'est sûr que les
cosmétiques disent que ça pas été testé
chez les animaux beaucoup
la définition d'un cosmétique bon ça me
fait un peu rire d'ailleurs non c'est
vrai mais je veux dire on dit que ça ne
doit pas traverser la peau ça reste sûr
la peau parce que si ça traverse une
pénétration ça peut rentrer dans la
circulation systémique sauf que bon il y
a quand même des crèmes moi je peux dire
moi mon fils qui était petit je mettais
des crimes est allergique fait que ouais
c'est possible
de dégradation qui avait dedans des
antioxydants
parce que dans une crème
je sais pas encore à l'heure actuelle
comment est-ce qu'on peut s'en sortir
oui il y a une intelligence artificielle
maintenant beaucoup beaucoup
ce qu'on appelle l'intelligence
artificielle maintenant on s'en sert
beaucoup pour
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
existe c'est relativement récent mais
déjà il y a pas près 20-25 ans on
faisait ce qu'on appelle un peu de
l'optimisation c'est à dire qu'on avait
des programmes mathématiques qui
fonctionnent un peu comme des réseaux de
neurones
tu nourrissait ton ordinateur avec le
plus de données possible comme ça ils
pouvaient te donner un résultat avec
plus tu donnes de l'information plus
il va réussir à être précis puis c'est
ce qu'on essaie de faire maintenant avec
peut-être que entière
du Big Data il faut vraiment les nourrir
à la pelle puis mettre cet exemple les
interactions
pour ensuite
être capable peut-être de donner un
résultat
plus ou moins précis par contre ce qu'on
appelait à la base l'optimisation des
fois là on a un résultat
qu'on pense être le meilleur puis on
prend un logiciel d'optimisation on
rentre toutes les manips pour les
expériences qu'on a fait pour y arriver
il va sortir autre chose
ça veut pas dire qu'il y a tort ça veut
pas dire non plus que nous on a tort et
ça veut dire qu'il y a peut-être
plusieurs résultats pour la même chose
faite avant d'être capable je pense
d'éliminer les animaux pour les tests de
médicaments à l'heure actuelle je pense
que ça va être difficile encore une fois
puis ça aussi les gens à faire confiance
à quelque chose qui a fonctionné sur un
animal imagine quelque chose qui a été
théorisé par un ordinateur
[Musique]
ça risque d'être un petit peu plus
complexe merci infiniment ça fait
plaisir infiniment c'était vraiment
super intéressant c'est moi qui vous
remercie merci bye merci d'avoir écouté
ce podcast jusqu'à la fin j'espère que
vous avez apprécié la conversation ça
prouve que vous êtes de réel fan de
conversation et du sans fil podcast et
on vous remercie vraiment beaucoup si
vous voulez avoir plus de contenu plus
de conversation c'est sur pitchian que
ça se passe il y a sur P3 non seulement
on met tous les podcasts en ligne au
moment où est-ce qu'on les tourne donc
on a beaucoup de semaines d'avance sur
le pétruan mais on fait aussi des encore
moins de filtres qui sont exclusifs au
Mambo est-ce que on parle d'homme Nicole
et moi de la conversation qu'on vient
d'avoir parce qu'on va un petit peu plus
en profondeur dans certains sujets qu'on
voulait aborder ou qu'on a aborder
pendant le podcast donc allez sur notre
page webcam les le lien vers ça va être
dans la description du podcast merci
encore une fois de nous avoir écouté
jusqu'à la fin